so first I'd like to
it's an honor to be able to speak here
today everything I'm talking about today
is joint work with Richard Kent the
University of Wisconsin and what I'm
going to talk about is a project to
create an image of thirsted skinning map
computationally so there's a long
history and tecmo a theory of focusing
on low dimensional examples where it's
possible to make meaningful pictures and
because the dimension of the tyco molar
space as a complex manifold is a linear
function of the Euler characteristic if
you're going to try to make meaningful
pictures you're really quite limited in
which examples you can focus on for to
make an actual picture that you can see
on a computer screen or on a poster or
something of a tech more space you're
you have to focus on either the
punctured torus or the four punctured
sphere those have one dimensional
technol or space and each of those tight
polar spaces is actually just the upper
half plane if you're trying to
understand some something like the
boundary of tech molar space the space
of projective measured laminations then
you can in some cases get by with
looking at the five punctured sphere or
the twice punctured Taurus in both of
those cases the tech more space is
two-dimensional over the complex numbers
and so the boundary is a three spheres
ample the poster for the for the the
poster for the alford's bears colloquium
includes an image showing the space of
simple closed curves on the five
punctured sphere realized as a subset of
the projective measured lamination space
which is a which is the 3-sphere
stereographically projected into r3 and
then mercilessly projected onto a
two-dimensional poster ok so what's the
actual focus of my talk today the goal
of this project was to make a picture of
thurston skinning map and that's not
really the ultimate goal the ultimate
goal is to make a meaningful picture
that might suggest things about the
skinning map about Thurston's
construction of hyperbolic structures on
compact manifolds where you might learn
something from these pictures but to
make a meaningful accurate picture that
allows you to understand thirst
map in some example so I'll define the
skinning map in a minute but I'll just
remove any dramatic tension from the
lecture by telling you which witch
low-dimensional techno space i'll focus
on it will be that of the four punctured
sphere the reason for that is that of
the two one dimensional complex
manifolds that are technically spaces
only the four punctured sphere can arise
from the connected boundary of a
hyperbolic manifold if you have a one
puncture once punctured Taurus you have
to have at least two of them because the
cusps have to pair up in in pairs okay
so let me start and I think I'll switch
to using the board for a little while by
just explaining what thirst and skinning
map is all about so what's the setting
it's going to be so M is going to be a
hyperbolic manifold with totally
geodesic boundary and for most of the
lecture I'm actually going to focus on
the case where the boundary is a surface
s which will be as it often is at the
outdoors because colloquium a connected
compact surface of genius at least two
okay so worried about this totally
geodesic boundary what I mean here is
that it's an infinite volume hyperbolic
manifold has a flaring end that can be
conformally compactified by a riemann
surface but also where that end has a
special type it's cut off by a totally
geodesic service
okay so here's M this totally geodesic
surface is actually a hyperbolic
structure on s so such a manifold and
this is not the most general setting in
which the skinning map can be defined
but it's the one all our examples will
fit into so such a manifold by the work
of many people out for its bears rob
martin masket sullivan Thurston has not
won hyperbolic structure not just the
hyperbolic structure it's presented with
but a whole space of hyperbolic
structures and I'll focus on the
geometrically finite ones geometrically
finite hyperbolic structures that are
actually parametrized by the tech molar
space of the boundary surface and that
map is at least in one direction is easy
to explain a riemann surface structure
on s which I'll I'll call X corresponds
to a hyperbolic structure on em that has
that riemann surface as its riemann
surface at infinity so here is X is
going to be the Riemann surface that
appears in this conformal
compactification so in one Riemann
surface at infinity of the hyperbolic
structure and I guess the reason that I
write Rho X here is that I'm going to
think of it as a representation of the
fundamental group of em into psl to see
corresponding to the uniform ization of
this manifold by h 3 ok so in this
picture there's at least one case in
which you can understand this if we
think of this totally geodesic surface
as a hyperbolic surface that that gives
a point in the technology space and for
for that one the Riemann surface at
infinity is also the that point in time
or space in general for a different
Riemann surface structure you'll still
have a hyperbolic structure on the
interior but this totally geodesic
surface will no longer be there there
will be some convex surface that bounds
a compact part of the manifold that
carries all the topology but it
we'll probably be quite different from
the Riemann surface at infinity so this
parametrization which uses the quasi
conformal deformation theory of kleinian
groups is I one of the major struggles
in this project is to avoid having to
understand this from a computational or
numerical perspective this map is a
little bit like the uniform ization
theorem it associates to riemann surface
structure some sort of rigid metric
geometric structure and the map in any
in any obvious coordinate system for the
technical group of em is some highly
transcendental map so what is the
skinning map all about it's the fact
that just like up there once you have
one of these hyperbolic structures you
can take the cover of em corresponding
to the fundamental group of the boundary
and I'll just point out that the fact
that the boundary is in fact that the
boundary is totally geodesic means that
it's fundamental group injects into that
of em the boundary is incompressible so
you can take the cover of em
corresponding to its boundary the
boundary subgroup I 1s and you get a
geometrically finite hyperbolic
structure on the surface cross the real
line that has now 2 hyperbolic
structures or two conformal structures
at infinity one of them is clear because
this end of the manifold carries the
fundamental group of s it lifts to this
cover and so you see a copy of the
Riemann surface X still out there at
infinity but this process of taking the
cover reveals a new Riemann surface
which is well let's just give it a name
is the image of X under the skinny map
of em ok so I've just reproduced this
slide that you've been looking after the
last three minutes on the board but what
this means as far as a mapping is that
the covering construction induces a map
from geometrically finite hyperbolic
structures on m 2 hyperbolic structures
on s cross I their respective al fours
bears parameterizations of their
hyperbolic structures give you a map
from tech more space to
tecmo space of the surface and tie color
space of the surface with the opposite
orientation and this map takes X to a
pair X and some new service to call
Sigma M of X okay this geometric leave
finite structures on surface costs
interval this is known as the quazy
folksy in space so what this is saying
is that the hyperbolic structure is on
em give you a family of quasi folks in
groups Kwasi folks in groups can be
thought of as pairs of remonte surfaces
and so the pairs of riemann surfaces
that arise are the graph of a map and
that map is the skinning net so that
sigma m as described here is a map from
the techno space of s to the tech boy
space with the opposite orientation this
is actually a holomorphic map and
thurston showed that if m is a
cylindrical another something well
actually something that follows from our
assumption that has totally geodesic
boundary but I'm stating this in the
generality in which the skinny map
exists the MSA is cylindrical then the
image of the skinning map is a bounded
subset of tech molar space since their
sins bounded image theorem okay so when
I said that the goal of the project was
to be able to see the skinning map in
fact what we're going to do is to try to
make a meaningful picture of the image
of the skinning map a bounded subset of
the techno space by working with the
four punctured sphere the technology is
just the upper half plane and so we're
talking about a bounded open set in the
upper half plane in the complex plane
couldn't get much more concrete than
that
so let me explain the main idea in this
construction it's to interpret the
statement that the skinning map maps a
Riemann surface X to another riemann
surface why as a statement about the
intersection of two submanifolds in the
character variety
so how is that going to work let me
point out something that that we all
know from teaching calculus that to say
that some point is in the the range of a
function is just to say that the
horizontal line with that y-coordinate
intersects the graph of the map so
similarly to say that a riemann surface
why is in the image of the skinning map
is really about about the intersection
between two sets one of them will be the
graph of the skinning map and the other
one is going to be the set of all quazy
folks in groups that have that riemann
surface y as their lower conformal
boundary structure so let me try to
develop that picture a little bit more
detail so what do we have here there's a
restriction map that well in fact it's
defined on character varieties so let me
introduce the character variety the
character variety of S is homomorphisms
from the fundamental group of s to psl
to see montolo conjugacy so these are
representations up to conjugacy and this
is where hyperbolic structures on s live
and similarly for the character variety
of them and these contain those spaces
of hyperbolic structures so Klaus a
fluke same space lives inside the
character variety of s and the space of
hyperbolic structures on em lives inside
the character variety of em and I'll
point out that the fact that the
fundamental group of s injects into that
of em or really just maps into induces a
restriction map on character varieties a
map from the character variety of em
into the character ID of s so it's
called restriction because this is just
the statement that when you have a map
from the fundamental group of em into
psl to see you can restrict it to a
subgroup of the fundamental group of
them like PI 1 of s so this is actually
a regular map between between algebraic
varieties both of these are affine
algebraic varieties
so let's think about what that
restriction map does well let's let's
think about it up here so this is all a
picture of what the statement the
skinning map of em takes the point X to
the point why means in terms of this
restriction map so here at the top we
have geometrical e finite hyperbolic
structures on em I've drawn that as an
interval it is that interval represents
the tyco Miller space of the riemann
surface s if you take a point in that
techno space and you apply the rink of
that that point X in tech myspace as a
hyperbolic structure on em applying this
restriction map to it is exactly taking
the cover of that hyperbolic manifold
corresponding to the boundary subgroup
and so you get some point here in Kwazii
fuchs in space the geometrically finite
hyperbolic structures on s cross i I've
drawn that as a square because I guess
in this model tecmo space is an interval
and so Kwazii fuchs in space is the
product of two of those the product do
two intervals so here this point in
class he fuks in space is on the image
of hyperbolic structures on em under the
restriction map this blue curve here but
it's also if the skinning image of X is
equal to Y it's also on the bear slice
of why this orange curve here so I'm
following following Sarah's convention
that if your talk is about two sets that
intersect one of them should be blue and
one of them should be orange so what is
the bare slice of why this is the set of
all classic books in groups so it should
introduce a notation I said that
hyperbolic searches on s cos I are
parametrized by Tyco more space cross
the opposite type muy space and i'll use
Q to denote that parameterization so Q
of XY is the closet vaccine group that
has X on one side and why on the other
so the Bears slice of why here why is a
point in the technology space with the
opposite orientation is the set of all
Kwazii books in groups of the form Q of
something and why
for fixed why okay so that's the
horizontal line in this graph picture
that's the set of all class he flicks in
groups that have some surface on the
bottom and the statement that sigma f of
x is equal to y is the statement that
those two sets the bear slice of Y and
the image of hyperbolic structures on em
under the restriction map that those two
sets intersect at that point okay that
ultimately we're going to create an
image of the skinning map by answering
the question is why in the image or not
and the preimage point X is going to
play less of a role here so in fact
let's forget about X for a minute and
and just think about this statement with
the bear slice and the image of
hyperbolic structures on em under the
restriction map intersect well the first
point is that none of this is really
computationally accessible the space of
hyperbolic structures were treating it
on the surface cost an interval we're
treating it as this product of tyco
moist basis but like I said that Alf
where's bears parametrization uses the
quasi conformal deformation theory is a
kind of transcendental object instead we
work with these these set the bear slice
and the restriction image in a nice
algebraic variety that contains them
namely the character variety of the
surface so let's let split place this
picture into that variety where it lives
the character variety of a finitely
generated group is an affine algebraic
set it has nice explicit coordinate
functions and so it's easier to work
there but this introduces the following
complication so inside of the character
variety of a surface group you have the
space of quasi fuchs in groups which is
an open set but it has a very
complicated boundary and inside of that
open set of quasi fuchs in groups both
the bear slice and the restriction image
so both of these curves that we've been
considering there actually are bounded
one of those is a consequence of
Thurston's compactness theorem for a
cylindrical manifolds an ingredient in
the bounded image theorem and the other
one is a consequence of bears inequality
which says that if you fix one side of a
quasi fuke same group you bound the
lengths of all geodesics in that
manifold so in fact what we study in
this problem
is is not directly the bear slice or the
restriction image but analytic
completions of those two things start
writing that somewhere
so you study analytic completions so the
idea here is that each of these sets
that we want to understand the
intersections between lives inside of
some analytic subset of the character
variety that is more directly accessible
to computation and it factors the
problem into two steps one of them is to
study those analytic completions and
their intersections and then the other
is to figure out which of those
intersection points actually correspond
to the original problem so let me
introduce the first one well remember
the hyperbolic structures on em those
live inside of the character iety of em
so this blue interval here really sits
inside of some affine algebraic said and
the restriction map is defined on that
entire set so the set of kwasi focusing
groups arising from hyperbolic
structures on em that sits inside of
some algebraic subset of the character
variety let's let's do that so here we
have the entire character variety of em
mapping by the restriction map into the
character variety of its boundary
surface its image is some algebraic sub
variety which is this blue thin blue
curve here and it has inside of that sub
variety there's an open set that's
accounted for by hyperbolic structures
on it ok and what about the bear slice
so the analytic completion here of the
image of hyperbolic structures on em
under the restriction map this is
contained in what I call a em up there
which is defined to be the entire image
of the character variety of em and then
you take it's a risky closure the
difference between the actual image and
the risky closure will play no role in
anything that I say I just want to be
honest here and this East ann's for
extension so we call this the extension
variety because it's a it reflects a
property that a representation of a
surface group may or may not have
if you have a representation of the
surface group it might be possible to
extend that to a representation of this
three manifold group that's compatible
with that with the inclusion of s as the
boundary event okay so you have a
representation to find here can you
extend it to the full fundamental group
of them if you can then you're in the
extension variety and it's possible you
might be in the extension variety even
if you're not of that form but you're a
limit of things of that form so that's
am am is an algebraic sub variety of the
character variety of s what about the
bear slice so that is contained in the
hollow know me by hiding to say
something about projective structures
the bear slice of Y is contained in hy
which is the set of hollow know me
representations of complex projective
structures online
what is the complex projective structure
and why it's well let me tell you one
way that you can get one if you have a
domain in the plane or in CP 1 and if
that domain is acted on by a group of
Mobius transformations freely and
properly discontinuously then the
quotient has a natural complex
projective structure you could take that
almost as a definition and one so one
way you could get that is you look at a
quasi a fluke same group that has y as
one of its boundary surfaces then the
domains of discontinuity of that causing
focusing group cover to riemann surfaces
why is one of them so any point in the
bear slice gives you a complex
projective structure just from taking
it's it's the quotient of its domain of
discontinuity on the other hand there
are many projective structures that
don't on why they don't arise from that
construction and the full set of Holland
only representations is actually a
holomorphic Lee embedded copy of a
complex vector space so this is the
image of the quadratic differentials on
why under the Holland owe me map so this
is where hall from the vector space of
quadratic differentials on Y into the
character variety of s this is a proper
holomorphic embedding
so remembering that we're eventually
going to be discussing a one-dimensional
tech boiler space you would probably do
well to think of the bear slice as a
disk it's isomorphic to the tech more
space and so you could think of it as
the unit disk or the upper half plane
this Holland I'm a variety in in that
same situation would be a complex line
the vector space of integrable quadratic
differentials on for punctured sphere is
one dimensional so this is like the disk
being contained in the complex plane and
all of that embedding into the character
variety now I've drawn in this picture
I've drawn the image of that Holland my
variety at some deliberately very
oscillatory complicated subset and it's
true I mean various things that are you
might think from this picture it true
that there are lots of spurious
intersections between the extension
variety in the hall and I'm a variety
that this holonomic variety returns to
Kwazii books in space many times that
some of those returns are completely
unrelated to the skinning map but
nevertheless we now have these two
analytic sets the whole enemy variety
and the extension variety and the
skinning map or rather the statement
that why lies in the image of the
skinning map is accounted for by some
intersection point between these sets
okay so like I said the hollow know me
writing is the image of the vector space
of quadratic differentials some of that
image corresponds to the the bear slice
that's actually the Bears embedding of
technol airspace depicted as this
vertical interval here and the space of
quadratic of rentals on why is actually
a fiber of the space of all projective
structures so remember hy is just the
whole enemy of projective structures on
the Riemann surface why if you allow the
riemann surface to vary you get the
space of all projective structures that
also maps to the character variety that
Holland owe me map is a local
homeomorphism and projective structures
form a bundle over the techno space of
which this is just a fiber ok so this is
this is what I would call the kind of
geometric picture that you can
understand a point that's in the image
of the character variety the a point
that's in the image of the skinning map
as an intersection between two analytic
sets one of them is the it corresponds
to this algebraic map between character
birth dates the restriction map the
other one corresponds to this hall amor
fake map from projective structures to
their holonomic representations and the
projective structures form a bundle /
techno space and you're interested in
one of those fibers and whether its
image intersects the extension variety
okay so I want to turn this now into a
diagram of spaces so at the top we have
the character variety of em so let's get
rid of the picture at left we have the
space of projective structures so this
is this is a diagram of the maps we were
considering so let let me introduce the
the other key player here in studying
the skinning map we're interested in
cases in which the whole enemy of a
projective structure is equal to the
restriction of a hyperbolic structure on
em so that's effectively studying what
you call the inverse limit of this
diagram the fiber product of these two
maps so let me write that definition
okay just continue here so what is this
thing FM this is the fiber product of
those two maps the hollow know me map
from projective structures on s bar to
the character variety of s and the
restriction map for the character
variety of em to the character variety
of us what that means is it's the subset
of projective structures x character
variety of em consisting of pairs that
map to the same thing so it's the set of
pairs of projective structure Z and a
representation row such that the hollow
know me of z is equal to the restriction
of Rome
let me just talk about dimensions for a
moment
so the Bears slice and let's say that n
is the dimension of the tech boys face
with either orientation then the bear
slice is essentially a copy of tech
Miller space so it's dimension is also n
it's inside it sits as an open subset of
this hall and I'm a variety so that also
has dimension n the space of
geometrically finite structures on M is
parametrized by that technol or space
that also has dimension N and at least
if we define the extension variety using
the right irreducible component of the
character variety of them that's going
to be the dimension of this algebraic
sub variety so what we have here are a
pair of n dimensional subsets of the
character variety of s which has
dimension to n so asking for
intersection points between these things
is a could be a well posed problem you
have to half dimensional submanifolds of
the character variety you expect their
intersections to be zero dimensional
similarly if you think about the fact
that the hall and only map is a local
homomorphism it follows that this fiber
product F is also n dimensional and it
comes equipped with a projection down to
the tyco molar space so our method is to
treat that projection as as something
like a branch cover so let me introduce
some subsets of this so we have the
fiber product FM inside of that you have
the sub set consisting of Kwazii fuchs
in groups so those are pairs of row
pairs z Ro where the whole enemy of z
which is the restriction of Roe is quazy
fuchs hand inside of that you have what
we're really interested in the part of
the fiber product that actually comes
from the skinning map I'll call that F
Sigma so those will be the set of points
in this fiber product that we can
construct from the skinning map and how
do we do that so associated to a point
associated to the statement that Sigma M
of X is equal to Y this determines a
point in the fiber product namely well
we need a projective structure so that's
going to be I'll write something and
then explain why it defines a projective
structure so it's going to be the
projective structure on why that's
induced by the quality flick same group
qxy and the hyperbolic structure on em
coming from the riemann surface x that's
the set of those such that Sigma M of X
is equal to Y all right this is all to
say that FM is defined by a very nice
intersection property to half
dimensional submanifolds of the
character variety finding their
intersections is equivalent to finding
FM down here at the bottom we have a set
that understanding it would be good
enough to understand the the skinning
image completely because it's a set of
pairs of a projective structure on Y and
a hyperbolic structure on em where Sigma
M of X is equal to Y this projects to
take more space and that projection
takes the point Q X Y and Rho X to Y so
the question becomes for which points in
tecmo is there a point in this fiber
product that lies over the fiber product
for Sigma so here's the one proposition
that makes it all work
I call it a proposition rather than a
theorem or something because it it's
just a translation of what the alford's
bears parametrization of hyperbolic
structures on em says so first FM it's
really only an analytic set but it's a
manifold in the neighborhood of the
points that we care about FM is a
complex manifold of dimension n
in a neighborhood of the closure of the
part we care about to
FM Sigma is the connected component of
the quasi fujian part containing the
totally geodesic boundary structure so I
said at the beginning that the manifold
is given to us with the totally geodesic
with a totally geodesic boundary
hyperbolic structure that means there's
at least one point in this fragra
product we already know it's the one
where this quality folks in group is
that Fuchs Ian group where Rho is just
the totally geodesic structure and that
lies in FM Sigma so inside of this full
fiber product which has the dimension of
techno space you look at the quasi Fuchs
inset that's some open set probably
countable union of connected components
and the one that contains the base point
we we know gives us the graph of the
skinning map and I guess the third point
is the one that makes the numerical part
work out three
at any point in FM stigma that lies over
why intec molar space that is a regular
value of the skinning map the two
submanifolds whose intersections define
FM intersect transversely p.m. and hy
intersect transversely at ok so i should
give this point a name p intersect
transversely and p
so here's how this becomes an algorithm
for computing the image of the skinning
map there are two steps the first is
let's start in the tech molar space of
the surface and start at a point where
we know I guess I'll point to this
figure so let's start at a point in the
technology space where we know some
point on this fiber product which is to
say we know that it's in the image of
the skinning map already and then we
start moving outward from that point in
tech more space and use Newton's method
to find intersections between the
extension variety and the holonomic
variety remembering that as long as we
don't run into a critical value of the
skinning map that's a transverse
intersection of two manifolds that it's
a isolated transverse intersection of
two manifolds so what I would say is
that having this base point is like
having an intersection point between two
manifolds moving in the tight polar
space of Y is to say we deform one of
those manifolds slightly we want to
locate a new intersection point so
that's a well posed numerical problem
finding the new intersection point is
lifting a path in the base tech most
base to a path in this fiber product so
practically speaking what we do is we
explore the one skeleton of a
triangulation of the upper half plane we
don't do anything fancy like use a
triangle tiling of the hyperbolic plane
because the combinatorics are slightly
complicated we do something very simple
which is we look at the triangle
equilateral triangle tiling of the plane
for some fixed small size of the
triangle so marching outward from the
base point we try to lift triangles one
by one two triangles in this fiber
product FM all the while paying
attention to whether we've left the
connected component that consists of
quazy folks in groups and which contains
the base point as soon as we've left
that quazy focusing component we're no
longer in FM sigma and so we're we're no
longer over the image of the skinny map
in the tech more space of s
so what what's the output of that
procedure that will produce a simplicial
to complex inside of the product of the
character variety of em and the space of
projective structures on s that
approximates FM at least some part of FM
and that the piece is big enough to
contain the entire FM Sigma the park
corresponding to the skinning map
exactly so here are the key steps that
allow this to be done numerically
so there are really three the first is
that Hall is computable so what is Hall
this is the map that takes a quadratic
differential and gives you the whole
enemy of the corresponding projective
structure so this means that hy is also
computable and this just uses the
integration of ordinary differential
equations in the complex domain
computing holla know me representations
of projective structures using this
method goes back to a paper of Keene
Roush vasquez bit later developments by
Porter and by um yamashita and
collaborators so our our implementation
uses a new implementation of this
ordinary differential equation solver to
compute the challah no mere
representation of protective structures
the second point is that the map the
restriction map then the character
variety of em to the character variety
of s is also computable and this uses at
least this is at least when the
fundamental group of em has at most
three generators this uses the so-called
friki trace calculus that present
compatible presentations for the
fundamental group of em and for the
fundamental group of s allow you to
compute explicitly and trace coordinates
what this map looks like and finally the
following is only a slight lie that the
question of whether or not a point is in
Kwazii focusing space is computable
almost so let me say what almost means
so here I'm referring only to s being
the punctured torus or the four
punctured sphere the associated
representations are commensurate so you
can reduce either one to the other and
this uses a criterion of Brian bowditch
in the character variety so here's
here's what voltages work gives it
doesn't exactly give you a way to test
whether representation lives in quality
folks in space but it gives you a way to
test whether or not a representation
lies in some set B the way the test
works is that you have to recursively
explore the tree of generating triples
for this free group on two generators
apply some numerical test of the traces
of each such triple you eventually get
some sub tree and if that tree is finite
then you're in this baggage set so that
gives some way of testing elements in
this set and what we know about this set
is that it is an open set in the
character variety and cause the efficacy
in space is a connected component
conjectural e so bowditch conjectures
that they actually agree that these two
sets are the same and that that would
mean that this gives an actual test for
whether a representation is causing book
saying or not but all that we actually
need in this in this approach is a way
to test for a component of something
that the component of the quasi books
and set that contains a given point and
so for that kind of problem just being
able to test whether you lie in in one
connected component is enough so all we
use here is that the voltage said is
some open set in the character priority
of which caused a folksy in space is one
connected component okay
alright so I want to demonstrate what
our program does in a moment but let me
just finish up this sketch of how it
works so what is the output of this
first step it's a simplicial to complex
that approximates this fiber product FM
and that at least at the level of all
the representations that are tested
seems to contain the quasi folks in part
of it so then we have this too complex
what we have to do then is test a bunch
of points in that too complex for
whether or not they are quasi books he
has a a fine mesh of points we've as
I've depicted in this picture we
probably get something like a few
hundred triangles but to make an
accurate picture of the image of the
skinning map we will then want to test
say millions of points in a very fine
mesh on this surface test whether each
one is quasi fuchs & or not and the ones
that are causing folks in we project
down to the tyke moist base and that
produces a picture of a subset of tyco
more space which is the image of the
skinning map so those two steps are
implemented in two different programs
first one we call the flayer for the
fiber product layers so it constructs a
surface that lives in a bunch of layers
like a branch cover over technically
space and the second one uses the output
of that runs that quazy focusing test on
a fine mesh and raster eyeses it
produces a bitmap image so what I'm
going to do now is demonstrate this
first program i should say just in a
word what the example manifolds are
going to be I've said nothing about the
four punctured sphere so far I've only
talked about the generality of a
manifold that has a connected compact
surfaces boundary so we work with
manifolds that have a four punctured
sphere boundary and all of these the
examples i'm going to show you i think
are obtained by gluing faces of the
regular ideal octahedron so there are
four manifolds that you can produce that
have geodesic boundary by gluing two
pairs of faces of the regular ideal
octahedron so i've shown here so imagine
of the eight phases of the octahedron
I've colored four of them red so divide
those into two pairs like the top pair
and the bottom pair glue those pairs you
have a bunch of choices for how to do
that but you only get four different
manifolds up to isometry of those three
have four punctured sphere totally
geodesic boundary and so those three
examples are the ones that we folk
stone initially I I guess I've drawn a
picture here of one of them this is
where you glue the top faces just by
sort of swinging one over at the top and
that so that gives one vertex in the
quotient and then you glue the bottom
pairs of faces with a twist the
resulting manifold is actually a genius
to handle body its boundary is a four
punctured sphere which you can think of
as the complement of two curves inside
of this genus to surface so this is a
paired manifold and the pairing annual I
are this light blue one the dark blue
one okay so that in fact all of the
manifolds that you get by gluing two
pairs of faces of the octahedron have
this structure it's a pair of curves in
the genus to surface you remove those
think of those as parabolics and then
you get a hyperbolic structure on the
genus to handle body with totally
geodesic boundary okay so I now I'll
just demonstrate what this fiber product
reconstruction looks like
okay so what I'm going to show you is a
picture oops is a picture that lives in
properly speaking it lives in a product
of the tyco motor space and the
character variety of the three manifold
group but I can't show you a picture of
that so I'm going to show you a picture
that lives in tech more space across the
real line so the type mo space is just
going to be this upper half plane which
is in the picture here so that's the
type motor space of the four punctured
sphere but this is in a
three-dimensional space and the third
direction the z coordinate here you
should think of as representing the
character variety of this handle body
character variety of em what I've done
is I've chosen some trace coordinate on
that character variety and used its real
part as a third coordinate here so you
may see in the picture you may see
intersections between things that don't
represent genuine intersections in the
character variety because there are
other coordinates that would separate
them but it's an attempt to make a
meaningful three-dimensional picture of
what's happening in this fiber product
so what happens in the program is that
we start with we start with some
triangle in the tech space 11 point of
which corresponds to the totally
geodesic boundary structure of em so
that point comes equipped with a lift
into the into this fiber product that we
already know about and then the
algorithm is going to just march outward
in the triangle tiling and one by one
try to lift triangles into the fiber
product first by lifting the one
skeleton and if it observes no monodromy
filling it into an actual triangle so
i'll show you an animation of that
process so warning the animation i'm
going to show you is not in real time
the program is not running right now
what i will show you took about 10
minutes to compute but i didn't want to
have 10 minutes of it running during the
lecture so we'll start out very slow and
then gradually speed up
okay so what's happening is it's
exploring the Tyco molar space of the
four punctured sphere one triangle at a
time and lifting those triangles to this
surface that lives inside the product of
projective structures and the character
variety of em so the the kind of dark
blue surface that's being constructed
here represents this fiber product so
what are the colors mean dark blue means
that every representation that's been
observed in that triangle is quasi fuchs
en pretty soon we're going to start
seeing some white triangles appear white
triangle means it seems that we have
left tight moist base in that no
representation that was explored in that
triangle was quasi fuchs Ian do we have
any of those well actually something
interesting already happened it appears
that this projection of the fiber
product to techno space has a branch
point which would correspond to a
critical point of the skinning map so
you can see this local behavior of the
projection will look kind of like the
map Z goes to Z squared ok so I think
yeah I think some white triangles are
starting to appear freeze it there so
that means it's it's going to stop
exploring once it finds that we've left
the connected component of the quality
of we've seen set containing the base
point light blue triangles if you see
some of those those are kind of boundary
triangles where some representations are
causing folks in that some are not it's
almost done now
so what's the end result it's a finite
simplicial complex this one equipped
with an explicit projection to the title
of the four punctured sphere such that
if you look at this complex and figure
out which subset of it is quasi books in
the connected component of that set
containing a base point projects exactly
to the image of the skinny map all right
so this is the output of the first step
in that algorithm the second step is to
then look at this surface choose a fine
mesh inside of each triangle and then
really test carefully which of those
points are causing fuchs in which are
not record all of the closet a fluke
seen ones and then project every single
one of them down to tech more space one
way to think of this is that this is a
course image of the skinning map it's it
has only the resolution of the number of
triangles that we've developed here but
then we can do a very careful test in
each triangle to get a fine high
resolution image of the skinning map so
that's what I'll show you now oh and
notice that there's there is a hole in
this surface let me see if I can show
you see hole right there then that's
because there was a triangle whose one
skeleton lifts to this fiber product
with non-trivial monodromy so that
wasn't filled in and that represents a
critical point of the skinning map where
the derivative of the skinny map is 0 or
at least it seems to represent that that
was was later proved that that's
actually there in Jonah gastrous thesis
ok so now I'll show you just a few
skinning map images that were produced
by this process so first the the example
that I showed you before this exact
hyperbolic manifold where it's the genus
to handle body with these two curves
drilled out as pairing annual I of rank
one cusps this one turns out to have a
rectangular boundary I refer to a
riemann surface structure on the four
functions here as rectangular exactly if
it's the double of a rectangle across
its boundary and then remove
vertices so here the this is not the
image that you were just seeing this is
another skinning image and it's a
bounded open subset of the tech molar
space it lies in the upper half plane
the region you're seeing in this picture
is from negative 2 to 2 on the real axis
and 0 to 4 on the imaginary axis so
that's the complete image of that
skinning map ok so i just want to show a
comparison between two things this is
the image of this is the actual skinning
image where the blue points represent
there is a pre image of that point under
the skinning map but this was
constructed by looking at the projection
of some big too complex inside of the
fiber product and so a bunch of points
here the gray ones were inside the fiber
product but when they were projected
they did not represent quality folks in
groups so just for each picture that I
show you you should imagine that there's
some surface living over it and the blue
part is the causative works in part this
gray part corresponds to points that
we're in the fiber product but not in
the graph of the skinning map so here's
a closer view of that one these pictures
can naturally be drawn in the unit disk
model of the hyperbolic plane because
each one comes equipped with the base
point the manifold has a totally
geodesic boundary structure it has
exactly one so it makes sense to draw
these in the unit disk model centered at
the totally geodesic point so here's a
picture for the first manifold with
rectangular boundary so this particular
hyperbolic manifold with totally
geodesic boundary was studied by
chesebrough and deploys their work on
trace fields and commencer ability of
link compliments ok so the second one is
the one I just showed you the
demonstration of and now you see that
when you project it down to techno space
some points are covered twice some
points are covered once this this
skinning map has a critical point where
it locally wraps to the one and if you
like the boundary of tech molar space
maps to a simple closed curve that sorry
maps to a closed curve that looks
something like this wraps around this
point and then continues so this is
drawn in the same in the same region in
the upper half plane there's the
projection of the full fiber product
surface
here's a closer view that hole is not
really a hole in the image it's in fact
that hole is showing you where the
critical point seems to be and here it
is in the unit disk model finally this
is my favorite of the minimum volume
hyperbolic manifolds with totally do
this boundary this is the one where you
glue both pairs of triangular faces with
a twist and you do it in a symmetric way
so that the boundary surface ends up
being the square for punctured sphere
square meaning you double a square
across its boundary and then remove the
vertices this one gives what to our eyes
was a very strange region in the upper
half plane it looks less symmetric than
any of the others this was also the most
computationally challenging one and you
can see that the algorithm had trouble
constructing the fiber product when it
was entering the thin parts of
technologists close enough to be able to
compute the full skinning image and we
were perplexed by this this picture
thinking this seems to be the most
symmetric hyperbolic structure wanted to
give the least symmetric skinning image
but then of course we do it in the unit
disk model and we realized ah the upper
half plane is a highly distorted way to
view a subset of the hyperbolic plane
that has a distinguished point so in
fact it has a it's a nice symmetric
image after all and there's the image of
the full fiber product in that same
model okay so these are the three
hyperbolic manifolds with four punctured
sphere boundary that arise from the
regular ideal octahedron drawn in the
same coordinate system red green and
blue and I just wanted to show you one
more example of how we might use this
visualization technique to develop
conjectures or try to understand the
behavior of skinning Maps a little bit
better so remember that the examples I
showed you before all have the following
simple form it's a genes to handle body
a pair of curves are drawn on its
boundary genus to surface those curves
are declared to be ranked one parabolics
and then you get a hyperbolic manifold
at least if the two curves are chosen
correctly so one thing that you could do
to create a family of such manifolds is
to take a fixed pair of curves and then
apply mapping class group elements of
of the genus to surface to them actually
the it only matters which element of the
mapping class group up to as a co set of
the handle body group but nevertheless
i'll refer to them as supplying actual
elements of the mapping class group so
we considered what happens if we take
that first example I showed you and
applied ain twists in one curve to the
pair and to get a family of hyperbolic
manifolds with totally geodesic boundary
in which the the pairing annuli are
getting more and more complicated so for
the first few Dane twists we could draw
their skinning images I know it looks
like three simple pictures here but in
fact the degrees of the algebraic maps
involved are blowing up very quickly in
fact they blow up even more quickly if
you look at pseudo a NOSSA of maps and
that's why we didn't consider a pseudo
no self example but for these first
three examples they all seem to look
quite similar and in fact this led us to
conjecture that if you just look at the
manifold in which you drill out the
geodesic representative of the curve
your Dane twisting along that it has its
own relative skating map this is a
manifold with a rank two cusp so I'll
just draw quickly draw a picture of what
manifold we're talking about now it's a
manifold in which you take the genius to
handle body you drill out some curve
inside the handle body and then you draw
some other curves on its boundary which
are going to be pairing annuli of
franklin cusps so this thing also has a
skinning map and we're able to produce
an image the image of that skinny map
and that seems to be the limit at least
for these first few examples it seems
that there's a kind of geometric
convergence for these skinning maps in
these date with families and after we so
this was as limiting picture is an
ongoing joint project with Jonah gastrin
Richard Kent and after the fact we
realized that if you just believe that
every theorem that's two for riemann
surfaces that are compact is also true
for remote services with cusps then this
would follow from a result of richard
kent so he proved that in in dane twist
families you have uniform convergence of
skinning maps though he is our indane
filling families you have uniform
convergence of skinning maps though his
results applied specifically to
services will help unctuous so okay so I
think I'm almost out of time I'll just
say that there is work in progress here
the next thing that you might try to do
is consider a manifold that has two
different boundary surfaces and look at
slices of its skinning map image so
there's a natural way to produce a
hyperbolic manifold with 24 punctured
sphere boundary surfaces by gluing faces
of the regular ideal cube octahedron in
hyperbolic space and we considered
slices of this where you look at the
diagonal in the x disk which is the
technology space of the boundary here
and various rotations of it and you get
a family of slices but unfortunately our
our program has some trouble lifting
triangles here so we we don't yet have a
full image of this skinning even slices
of this skinning map image for the cube
octahedral manifold ok so I'll just end
by saying that this was all implemented
in Python yeah with a little bit of sea
and scythe on used to write an extension
that the CP 1 structures library that
was used is already open source and you
can find it on my github page and that
the flayer this fiber product layer
reconstructor will be open sourced as
soon as we're done with it ok thank you
you